[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time i'm
rachel it's great to meet you
i'm calling in from nashville today so i
have a different background behind me
um if this is your first hangout
this is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and chat
about data science leadership
questions you're facing
and what's going on in the world of data
science
so we want this to be a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone so there's three ways
that you can ask questions
you can jump in live and raising your
hand on zoom works well for this
you can put questions in the zoom chat
just put a little star next to your
question if you want me to read it
or else i'll just call on you to to jump
in the conversation too then we also
have a slido link that tyler will share
in just a second where you can ask
questions anonymously too
just want to reiterate we love to hear
from everyone no matter your level of
experience or area of work
and with all that i'm so happy to be
joined by my co-host for today
darren erie darin is director of data
science at arrowhead general insurance
agency
and darren
love to kick things off with having you
introduce yourself and maybe share a bit
about your role and the work that you do
sure
um so thanks for having me today
um so i lead the data science team at
arrowhead general insurance
arrowhead is
one of several
subsidiaries within
our parent organization brennan brown
insurance
and
we're kind of set up as like a shared
service within the organization so we're
very
decentralized and you know not every
um you know
subsidiary
within brandon brown has
their own data science team
you know looking at data
you know some sometimes they haven't
even looked at their data right
so so our team is there to provide
support
for those types of needs
it's not always something where we're
building a predictive model
most of the time it's just trying to
find value in the data that they already
have and you know what their data
is
you know
what what the data actually looks like
so
sometimes we'll try to find
business value in that data
whether it's
you know trying to improve their
underwriting functions
sometimes we'll try to look for ways to
price
insurance products
but in other cases you know sometimes
it's just looking at the data and
you know trying to understand how to
affect the bottom line
so that's kind of high level
that's great
how does that engagement usually work or
how do you get in touch with the teams
or work together with them
yeah so
um
we everything is budgeted of course
so when we are
planning for our budget for next year
which usually is in a late summer
we make
a like an email list of anyone who's
interested in
um you know doing things related to data
science and analytics and we have kind
of like a menu so to speak of like
here's what we've done and here's what
we're capable of are these things that
you're interested in doing
and so that will get sent out to
you know the other subsidiaries within
our organization
um and they'll reach out to us and then
we'll have initial calls with them
and and try to understand what their
actual problem is
sometimes it's you know they jump
straight to like i want to have i want
to have a machine learning model i want
to i want you know deep learning to do
something you know cool right and that's
not always the case
sometimes
you just start off simple just looking
at the data itself and trying to
understand
what the problem is
and building a solution for that problem
um versus you know building that shiny
object that they think that they want
but they really don't
i imagine that takes some good
communication skills too
yeah and sometimes it's setting
expectations um
you always want to be clear
um you know what
whatever you're building what it's going
to be capable of doing and what its
limitations are
um
i think we're pretty lucky within our
organization um not many people that
i've worked with
um they all have a pretty good idea of
what we're capable of and the
limitations and
and for the most part they're always
pretty invested in the work that we do
so
you know having that
stakeholder investment
i think we have a much easier time than
other organizations at least from my
experience
while we wait for questions to come in
from everyone here i'm i'd love to ask
you what is something that you're really
excited about in data science right now
we're we're thinking about the year
ahead
[Music]
um
for me personally i think there's a lot
of opportunity within the insurance
industry to make a difference
um you have all these insured tech
startups trying to you know disrupt the
industry
right
we are a much more formal insurance
company
so um
you know i think we're kind of catching
up to using
data more efficiently and effectively
within the organization
so from from my perspective there's a
lot of opportunities for the data
scientists
to
build meaningful products you know
whatever that might end up being whether
it's a dashboard
or a report that provides some insights
to provide business value a predictive
model right um
we have a lot of opportunity to make a
difference
um whereas you know i think other spaces
you know and i think a little bit more
competitive and um i think the
leadership on our
in our organization
makes it a big priority for us to
leverage data and analytics um
to make sure that we don't fall behind
are you hiring a lot of people right now
or what does the team look like how many
people yeah so we're we're a pretty
small team um
it's so i mentioned we're a
decentralized organization so there's
other teams um within the larger
organization that does
data and analytics they might be doing
something different
one team is very focused on on bayesian
statistics
for example
and they have a different client focus
again our we're kind of like internal
consultants so we're helping the
businesses internally
um there are some other teams that are
focused on
helping the
business with customers externally
so
um
sorry i kind of like drifted off what
was the
the original question
no just as you were talking about the
work that the team does and the big
opportunity to make a difference i was
curious if you were hiring
across the team
yeah so we're a pretty small
organization our small team we have
right now two other data scientists on
the team
um and then
we
are looking
at hiring another data analyst
and
we have an intern starting in the summer
as well
so we're hoping to
have that person grow within our team
and
that
position hopefully would end up becoming
a full-time position within our team so
hopefully by the end of this year we'll
have four other people
awesome i see there's a few questions
coming in on from the chat andreas would
you want to jump in and ask that
question
sure i'm always interested in someone
who has a title that looks like they're
a bit managerial
how much of it is managerial how much
can you still do hands-on technical
stuff and is it something you can decide
for yourself or is it sort of dictated
to you
[Music]
yeah that's always i think a hard thing
to balance when you're at a position
where you're managing a team and you're
in a technical space
i think other people have mentioned that
you don't
want to lose that technical skill set if
you can
i don't do
the day-to-day
like modeling or analytics and looking
at the data specifically that's kind of
what the rest of the team does
um so a lot of my time is spent kind of
like
doing project management product
ownership you know
um
trying to you know remove any roadblocks
and working with the stakeholders to
make sure that you know
we have a you know a path forward
um because that sometimes can happen
where you know priorities change and
then the business
has a different priority they want to
switch projects
um
but
uh i don't know it's it's it's kind of
difficult um i was talking to a friend
of mine about this yesterday and he's
spending fifty percent managing and
fifty percent um you know doing
technical work
and
um
at that point he doesn't have time to
work on the projects and
have that project management hat on
and you know move things forward because
he's still involved in the technical
side of things so i think you do kind of
let go
of that technical role so to speak um
so my time if it is technical it's kind
of like
making things a bit more efficient or
making sure that our apis are
that we have because that's how we
service our models
are running
efficiently um
i kind of have a unique perspective
because i have an i.t background so i
used to do like systems administration
so
um
we use you know our studio products so
we have our studio workbench we have rco
connect and then package manager so i
manage all that infrastructure
and the
servers that host those products
so making sure that that kind of stays
available
and
you know
i think one of our goals for our team is
making sure that those apis that we have
released
as production that they stay operating
during business hours so that's kind of
a challenge that i have to kind of
balance and
sometimes that ends up with me you know
working more than i should i think and
especially during off hours when i have
to do like you know the it maintenance
stuff
um
but it's it's a need that i think that
our team has to have
and i i think that's also one of the
things that gets kind of brought up is
you know how do you work with it
um as a data science team and
i kind of take that responsibility so
that we don't have to rely so heavily
on an it team to do what we need to do
technically
um so it makes us more agile to to make
things work the way we want it to work
um
yeah that's i kind of went off on a
tangent there but um
in in short i don't do a lot of coding
as much as i'd like to
um when i do it's kind of just making
uh little tools here and there to make
this more efficient as a team and to
monitor things
but the actual like data analytics
building models
i haven't been doing that as much
that's interesting that you
say you wear two hats obviously or many
hats but are doing the i.t
administration as well
is there a point where you think
that would get handed over to i.t or
um
i mean i think that would always be nice
and you know i think
fortunately we have a close relationship
with um the people
in rit to make you know significant
changes if we need to but once it's kind
of in place
then there's not much else that needs to
be done
the things that
uh
you know that i can handle are you know
just day-to-day things that are really
small and doesn't require a lot of
effort so once everything's working in
place and it's not too much of a
responsibility but if something isn't
working then of course that's kind of
when you know everything is put off to
the side and that's when you have to
work with it to understand like what the
problem is and it is a networking issue
um you know
is it something on the
um you know the other side where
the the business the subsidiary the
other company that we're working with if
their calls aren't coming in correctly
as we were expecting it to making sure
that there's nothing on their end that's
the problem
um
yeah it's kind of kind of a mixture of
problems that you have to deal with
i see um ishwar you just put a question
into the chat a bit earlier too do you
want to jump in and ask that live
yep absolutely hey everyone hey darren
um i'm ishvar i'm a data scientist at
nissan here in the supply chain
manufacturing assembly plan basically in
tennessee
um so
as you mentioned uh in the discussion
that uh looking at deep learning
and neural net stuffs um so i just i was
just curious if you
have or your team has ever experimented
or um try to work on the deep learning
or neural nets at least if not you know
in the level of computer vision i
understand in in the instruments
industry as i'm working on
several projects but it doesn't much
need
to train very high uh capacity deep
learning and neural net models
so i was just curious if you have you
see any potential
opportunities to work on
those deep learning models
that can be applied in into the
insurance industry um
being specific if you have your team has
thought about
looking at
if any deep learning models can be
utilized to
make your
project or the project you're working on
to make it more robust
or
at least you know if it is 98 to make it
99 um or near you know closer to perfect
so
just kind of um to make the point of
discussion
yeah that's that's always a fun question
to think about um short answer is our
team does not do any deep learning um
i think in insurance industry as a whole
yeah i think there's opportunities too
um you know
i think
you know i could be wrong i'm not sure
how other insurance industries are
thinking about it but
um
you know there's a lot of investment in
that right it's it's kind of you're
going into like an r d focus versus like
developing a product that could actually
be used and you know there's a high
likelihood of you know the business
using it
um
so so there's certain risks involved
with building
products that leverage deep learning
um
but i think it depends on the
application so
um
from a very
simple
perspective i mean just
being able to read
you know handwritten documents that are
scanned there's a lot of scanned
documents that are you know still being
used within our industry
usually it's typed out or something on
some form but there's always some going
to be some handwritten forms and stuff
and so being able to extract that
information
um
and and uh you know leverage you know
handwritten
and writing recognition
for
obtaining that data that text and
putting it into a structured format and
that's always going to be a common
[Music]
application
[Music]
that is going to be needed in insurance
industry although i think now that
there's there's so much of that
available like in any
you know industry that you can just buy
something off the shelf and you don't
have to have a data science team
dedicated to solving that problem
um
same thing with like images and if
you're looking at
you know trying to process claims
much more quickly and efficiently right
like if you take pictures of your car
because you got into a car accident you
want to estimate
the the damage of that claim um you know
sooner than later right you don't have
to send a field agent out to inspect the
car and look at it you can just take
pictures
um
so is that something that could also be
done i don't know anyone that's i'm sure
there are people that are looking at
doing that i don't know if there's
companies that are
doing that in production and like you
have customers sending in
their claims that way i haven't had a
car accident in a while but
um you know that's something that i can
see
being done as well
have you thought of
the nlp and in the team i don't know if
you have any models running on the nlps
um for the as you mentioned about text
analytics or understanding the claims
and so on um
is is there uh what type of model that
there are right now in production
specifically built by your team um
is
is that focus on nlp and uh neural nets
some kind of computer vision involved on
it or
yeah yeah so we haven't done anything
related to computer vision but we have
done projects related to nlp
um so we've used spacey for example to
extract
um you know
more meaningful information from
bodies of text
to to make
you know
more efficient decisions
um
but i wouldn't say it's it's like it's
not deep learning it's still within that
machine learning space
yeah
okay
yeah thanks
thanks erin thanks for the questions too
just a reminder if anyone wants to ask
anything anonymously too you can put it
through on slido
or just raise your hand and jump in
um but i wanted to ask you darren when
you were mentioning apis and
using apis in production would you be
able to share
a bit more about what that looks like
and what yeah so
i think one of the common problems
that
the businesses that we work with
from an underwriting function
is knowing
if you have
uh you know
30 applications to go through you know
these are insurance applications and as
an underwriter you have to make decision
about which ones to go through
and if you only have you know time to go
through 10 of them
how are you going to prioritize that
so
we have built an api that predicts the
likelihood of you know that submission
winning
with our company
um and so we'll give a grade out for
that submission
and so if you have like a list of 30
submissions
each one has a grade so a b c d f or
whatever
um and that way the underwriter can
you know order those rank from a's b's
and focus on those first
um
and so so our api basically takes data
um you know the core
you know data inputs of that submission
feeds it into our server
and then we send a response back with
that predictive grade
so that's kind of like a common example
that we like to use when we're talking
about apis and how we use that within
our team
that's great thank you
i see there's a question that just came
through on slido
um and it was do you think that
insurance companies are
underrated or misunderstood regarding
how innovative they are
oh yeah i think so yeah when i when i
joined this company two years ago um you
know i was just looking for a new
opportunity
and
uh i was working with recruiter and he
told me about this position i was like
oh insurance like that sounds kind of
boring
um and
all i knew about insurance at the time
was that i was paying for it and it's
cost me a lot of money
and i really understand the need in the
business need of insurance and how it
works and and also how wide-ranging
insurance is when you think about it
like everything in business needs
insurance
right because the business wants to
minimize the risk and you know hand it
off to somebody else by paying small
amounts um you know on a monthly or
annual basis so
um
the opportunities that i think
we have
on our team are so significant because
the the our company touches a wide range
of products you know when you think of
insurance it's like auto
health
home insurance you know some just
standard stuff but
there's
insurance products for a liability for
you know dentists or lawyers
bookstores have their own special
insurance right
even when you're looking at professional
liability insurance there's different
liability insurance for different
professions and
how you apply and solve their problems
for their data
um it's it's so unique
um
so
yeah i think it's pretty underrated um
just because
it just sounds boring
but when you go into it and you kind of
delve into the problems a bit more
then they're all very unique and they
all have different problems that they're
they're trying to solve and
again as i mentioned i think
the insurance industry as a whole is
still kind of trying to catch up to use
and leverage their data and
so it provides us with a
unique opportunity for us to make a big
impact
what's the most exciting
opportunity you think or
a problem that you're helping the team
solve that you're most excited about
um i don't know if there's anything
um specific um we've had a lot of cool
projects that we've worked on
um
you know part of that is related to
using nlp um it was kind of the first
time we were able to apply
um
you know that type of modeling
and approach to solve a problem
um a lot of our problems are kind of
focused more on just you know
you know basic
uh
statistical methods right and we don't
do anything really complex because it
doesn't require
more complex methods
you know we always look at more advanced
machine learning models when when we're
assessing
the predictability of
the work that we do
but
you know we
it doesn't compare to the explainability
and
the ease of use and maintenance of you
know
using you know
regular regressions
um
we yeah we compare
you know those types of models to
something that's more
machine learning focused and they
perform just as well
well thank you
i see alex you just asked the question
in the chat do you want to jump in
sure i was always curious about this in
insurance it seems like
data science and acura actuarial science
could be like
doing almost similar things and so i'm
kind of curious
what it's like
at an actual insurance company so
yeah
yeah so our team
uh is organized so we have a data
science site and then an actuarial
science side um so
both teams report to the same person
but there are separate groups and they
work on different problems
the actuarial team
looks more specifically
at the insurance products and whether
they're meeting their profitability
targets
um whether they're looking at you know
do we need to make changes in the rate
at which they
you know charge um
the product right to make sure that
they're meeting their profitability
goals
um so they're looking more specifically
at claims
and what types of claims are relating to
large losses and how that affects the
pricing
um of
um you know those those lines of
business
um
to make appropriate
changes to
um
the final price of it
we kind we don't really
delve too deeply into the insurance
specific
problem set it's more you know just
operating as a business how can we make
better better business decisions
um
we don't know enough about insurance and
from an actuarial perspective
to to kind of make those types of
decisions um so that's kind of how we
make that distinction um
on our on our organization
if i can ask another question i'm kind
of curious
do you see any actuaries that want to do
more data science work or do you see
data scientists that want to do actuary
work like anecdotally what do you tend
to see if any if any uh of that happens
yeah i think that depends on on the
individual person um and kind of what
they've been exposed to um i've had some
data scientists uh or we i've had like a
data scientist position open
with people who have some actuarial
experience
and they
apply or want to change from an
actuarial to a data scientist position
because they care more about like the
data and the modeling
versus i guess the
the specific problem space of just
insurance and
pricing and they also they also really
like the coding i think aspect of it
um although there's that's not to say
that with an actuary you don't you can
still code and stuff right um i think
it's just you're more into it when
you're in the data science space
um especially if you're you know
building out you know
apis and
you know pipelines to handle data i
think there is that
love of just working with data um
that i think attracts some people to the
data science side
um versus the actuarial side you're you
know you're really focused in just
insurance
um
the other way around i haven't seen that
as much
where you have someone interested in
data science someone's moved to the
actuarial site
i think also with the actuaries they
have other things that they have to be
mindful of right they have exams that
they have to take
while they're working which takes
several years so
um you know
if you're looking from a professional
development background you know
if you haven't worked or done any
programming and it you know that takes a
lot of significant effort initially
especially if you're coming from like a
traditional excel background
so being able to try to do your work
while also learning how to code and take
those exams
you know that's really hard
so that takes a lot of time commitment
thanks aaron
i see ethan you put a question into the
chat as well if you want to jump in
yeah um hi there nice to meet you
um i just want to check because we talk
about machine learning models and you're
selecting
which models to use i was wondering if
there's a factor of
interpretability or sustainability you
would need to consider
when choosing model when you're working
in insurance because i know like
for example financial industry are quite
heavily regulated in terms of you need
to explain what the model is doing so
you can't just throw down a box model
if it comes to you know deciding what
premium people are paying or you know
what the
interest rate that they need to be paid
so and also probably not just regulation
but also from a ethics
standpoint you need to understand is
that any particular subgroups that are
um being priced or
being predicted
differently than the other
yeah so those are two really good
questions um
so with the interpretability and and how
it relates to you know regulation that
hasn't something we've run into
um
when i when i think of interpretability
it's it's more
on the
business stakeholder side
uh and having them
understand that the models that we're
building how it works
uh you know if if we're taking in four
inputs for the model that we're building
to make a decision on something
you know how does
a change in one of those inputs affect
the output
um so that makes it really
straightforward when it's something like
like uh some type of regression versus
some some more machine learning uh
approach
um although there are approaches now i
think that are
um
within the machine learning space where
you can make things a bit more
interpretable
um
i think it's just easier for us on our
end to just uh
focus on the interpretability from those
regression models
um
so yeah it's really just about being
able to communicate to the stakeholders
how those models work what can they
expect what are the limitations of the
model
um
and
and being able to do that effectively
with the ethics side of things that's
something that's always been on my mind
unfortunately i don't think we've run
into
that type of problem um you know making
sure that we use data responsibly
um that whatever data that we're using
for the model
isn't going to create some sort of bias
against you know any type of groups
or you know
it's
applying you know
data
features just something that might
you know
inadvertently cause some problems down
the road right that's that's something
that you always want to try to avoid
um
so yeah from a from an ethics standpoint
um there hasn't been something we've
explored too deeply but it's something
that's that's always on my mind when
we're building something
that's really interesting
federica i see you have your hand raised
you want to jump in
hello
so
uh nice to meet you all
so i am i like to jump in on this uh
discussion because i am a naturally
so that's why
um
i wanted to ask a question um
about
what type of uh
area you cover within the authorial
[Music]
department
department so you do maybe i missed the
first part so you do
there's a life insurances there's no
life insurances there i don't know
pensions government the education that's
because actually covers uh
quite uh
wide area because we are uh
kind sort of uh
i won't say
analysts because uh
it
sounds like a bad word but we we do
research we do analyze things
we do government regulatory standards it
depends by your area so
we may be able to code and take care of
i don't know like
shiny apps and
uh websites
uh so some the the there's um
our is a specialization so we have
statistician and then we are specialized
in in a particular area
which contains some areas other some
areas and i wanted to say to to ask you
which area are you covering so your
company is covering at the moment
yeah so
from the
actuarial standpoint um you know our our
lines of business typically focus on
property and casualty
uh so we don't we're not focused on like
health insurance
um
that type of that type of um focus
but in terms of the property casualty
side
our organization
kind of focus at least for what we focus
on is really niche
business types so
that can range from just like small
restaurants and small businesses to
workers comp
um
i mentioned liability insurance uh
there's also some products related to
schools
and you know property and liability
insurance for for education
um
it kind of ranges so
each actuary i think kind of has like a
specific focus
uh so they're not like spread too thin
so one of them i know that focuses more
on personal property
type lines um
but
i wouldn't be able to say much more than
that other than that they do have areas
of focus
um
yeah
i hope that answers your question
uh yes sure thank you
thank you
and i see there was also an anonymous
question that said you've piqued my
interest with the insurance for
bookstores what data factors uh what
data factors into the rates they receive
so that i don't know um i know that we
have insurance products focused on
bookstores um
but but that's not something that we've
uh
worked with directly um as a team
so
i would be interested as well i mean
there's there's lines related to like
truckers
um and there's other really like niche
insurance products that we work on but
we don't we don't work on all lines
um
there hasn't been i guess a need but
those would be really interesting to
work on
uh something you just said right there
got me thinking like do you also do
does your team do data science to figure
out what are other data products you
could create or like niche
areas to focus on
oh um
i think so we haven't gotten to that
point where we like branching out into a
new type of insurance product
but our team does
look at ways where we can target more
effectively of course
right so if we have
um a set of um you know customers that
do really well with these types of
products
how can we more effectively target them
or increase that range of customers
um to improve the business that you know
that's something that i think is pretty
common but to develop a different type
of insurance product that we haven't
been doing before
that would be a new type of thing we
would work on
i get to ask you a lot of questions
until someone jumps in here so feel free
to raise your hand put it in zoom or use
slido too
but something i've been curious about
with
um
understanding insurance data and how you
like decide who is a good customer for
you
um
okay personal example but
like i live on a one-way street where
people like always back up down the
street and they will hit my car so i've
gotten a hit twice within the past year
but it's like
i'm not the one driving and getting in
an accident so eventually will that be
seen as a cusp would i be seen as a
customer you don't want to
have because of that street
um
you know what i mean like like like
accidents versus like when a car is
parked versus when somebody's driving
so we we actually don't get too involved
in in that type of data um
yeah it's it's
um
we have worked with claims data
um
but but in terms of like
looking at data to see what types of
accidents there are and and trying to
reduce those or minimize those that's
not something that we've we've looked at
too closely
um one of the projects that we worked on
is related to subrogation or kind of
like the ability to
you know pursue legally um money that's
that they're owed because it wasn't
at the insured's fault it was somebody
else's fault
um
so being able to know the likelihood of
segregation opportunities
um due to an accident um you know that's
that's something that we have done
um
so kind of just looking at the claims
data itself is always really interesting
when you're kind of researching those
problems because you're you're looking
at like how the accident happened and
yeah these really interesting stories
um kind of like how you describe where
um you know
someone
did something
really ridiculous and
it leads to an accident that you don't
want happening
yeah
i always think it's really interesting
to think of the people and the data and
like the stories behind the data
yeah yeah and that kind of you know
um
that brings up a good point too because
everything that you're working with
there's people behind the data
um
and
it just kind of
changes your perspective a bit um about
how you're using that information and
making sure it's being used responsibly
um
yeah
definitely
i see santiago you asked a question in
the chat if you want to jump in
hey rachel uh hey darren you mentioned
working with internal stakeholders and
how you uh highlight interpretability as
one of those uh as a factor i guess in
deciding
the types of solutions you and the team
build i had a general question about
what else
do you do to help ensure that your ideas
or mvps or a particular solution you're
working on
are well received by your internal
customers and then
is there a particular framework you
follow
for example
i've started to read about
product life cycle management uh but
applied to data investments so like
design principles but for data products
so just curious to see what you're doing
yeah um that's that's definitely
something that's always on my mind about
how to more effectively communicate to
stakeholders
and and make sure that they're aware of
you know what we're building and that
they're completely invested in what
we're building
so kind of in that agile mindset being
able to frequently meet with those
stakeholders is important
um you know whenever you're making major
decisions or have questions about
something making sure that they're
available to answer those questions
we we have a playbook
data science playbook for for building
out models
when when we are building models
and that generally follows a path of you
know initial kickoff
um you know trying to understand what
their business problem is
um if we do build out a solution what is
it going to look like
i think and sometimes
they're like oh okay an api
yeah
but they don't realize like what that
takes to integrate an api uh because
you're gonna need software engineers to
implement that and you know process that
data more effectively
um however you know however they're
going to process it and display that
information
um
and also making sure that it's part of
their business workflow so if they're
adding this new feature
how is the business going to use it and
and continue using it so it's not just
something where they implement and it
kind of gets left in the dark
so
um you know we we do try to follow this
this playbook to make sure that you know
we follow the steps that were
to make us as successful as we can
that doesn't always happen but we try
our best
so
in terms of making sure that they're on
board
um
when we before we start building the
model you know we just talk about their
data and what it looks like because we
have to do that anyways and it's kind of
a service to them because they probably
haven't looked at the data at that grand
of a scale
you know they're kind of seeing things
quarter to quarter year to year
um but we'll take a whole look at the
data and and
provide them with what we're seeing and
the perspective that we're seeing
especially because we don't have that
you know
expertise in their business
um
and get their input and
we always ask for their hypotheses
and
and what they think will lead to
you know what we're trying to predict
uh and that kind of helps us understand
what their problem is and
include their own
um ideas into the project as well and i
think that causes that results in some
investment and some ownership on their
their site too because they're kind of
partnered with us to build whatever
we're building for them
um
and when we have the model built out and
you know we evaluate it and we see like
the accuracy you know
um we provide them with several examples
um and the variation
of that data
um
to kind of show the limitations of what
that you know final product will look
like
and usually they have a sense like okay
that makes sense like i understand like
based on these inputs why you would
predict that
um
and i think that helps out a lot too
when you're spending the time to walk
them through that process
and they see it working
um
and what the result ends up being and i
think that really helps with uh getting
[Music]
them on board i hope that answers their
question
yeah that was really great it seems
obvious in hindsight but having a
playbook seems tremendously useful
so you're not uh
ad hoc like the wild west just doing
something different every time
yeah and then sometimes like you might
forget small little details so at least
you have something a reference to um
when you have when you have a playbook
that works
got it thank you so much
it sounds like
you are so
thoughtful in your approach to working
with the business as well like having
the
data science menu and then the playbook
and
i'm curious
where you learned that or um
how we all can can do that as well
um well to be fair that that data
science menu is actually from my boss
and he kind of came up with that idea
the player the playbook was kind of
uh came out
out of necessity um because i forget
things
um so i mentioned like you want to make
sure that when you when you do certain
projects you don't forget things and i
tend to forget things so i always write
things down and having this playbook
also kind of
provides a visual of
here's what we're going to do with you
and this is what the steps look like and
so that kind of lays out the land for
them when we work with them it's like a
flowchart basically
um just so they can see the complete
picture
versus just talking about it and being
kind of vague and
at least you have some documentation
that way too so i think a lot of it just
comes out of
you know as as i
joined this team
you know finding the problems that
you encounter and finding ways to solve
those problems as they come up so you
don't just kind of
you know
i think you want to be reactive to those
problems right and find solutions to
that so that the next time it happens it
works better obviously
um so i'm very mindful of like if
something's not working how are we going
to be able to fix it so it doesn't
happen again so we do our team does do
like retros every two weeks just like a
software engineering team
um for when things don't work well and
ways we can improve the team we kind of
address those pretty frequently
um and there's a time and space for that
to happen too versus
um you know just as they come up like
i think having that dedicated time
really helps
thank you that's really helpful
i see there's quite a few other
questions in the chat um someone put in
one i think it might be your initials
rbmv
but if you want to jump in yeah
yeah sorry i forgot to change it oh no
worries hi robert
hi
um so you when you mentioned the actual
team and your team sort of you know
being on two sides of
um a house with a similar supervisor it
reminded me a bit of
my team or we're a data science team
within a public health department so you
know obviously epidemiologists model and
write code we also can model and write
code and so carving out the space of our
work and the space of their work
um can sometimes be tricky so i'm
curious do you work with that team and
build products for them are you you know
leveraging similar infrastructure like
how do you
manage the relationship there when like
often you could end up working on
similar
bodies of work
um
you know
from my perspective like we end up doing
a lot of technical stuff
and more of the software engineering
type things and i'm curious if there's a
similar kind of relationship there
um any sort of
takeaways from that relationship sort of
best practices for working well
um i'm not sure if i can say anything
about best practices but it's similar to
your approach robert where we kind of
our team focuses more on the technical
um like statistical
um
software engineering type approach
whereas the actuaries
again they're really focused on the
insurance and the insurance products
so there's a lot of things in insurance
that i don't know um so many things that
are very technical an insurance side
that our team
you know isn't as familiar with so we
lean on them for you know understanding
the data sometimes like you know
what does this
data point mean like what does this line
of business mean and can you provide
some business context on
what this data looks like um
i have no idea i don't have a lot of
information about like rate changing and
how to make things profitable like like
i have
i can use the words right anything else
than that like i don't know much so so
that's how we work with the actuaries um
but for the actuaries you know they
don't always have the data that they
need to work efficiently and effectively
so sometimes our team does step in to
help you know clean that data when it's
coming from different data sources
um you know that's that's a big
challenge for them right now where you
know they're getting data from the
insurance carriers and it's like you
need to excel files and you know when
you're doing vlookups and pivot tables
you can only do that so much before it
gets a bit too much to handle um in
excel and so you need to provide some
some better framework for that and some
infrastructure so our team does kind of
help out with that effort too
yeah we're
also
trying to get them on board using our
tools which can be a challenge sometimes
there's like a bit of a tool disparaging
um kind of gap that we're trying to
mount but yeah the the difficult thing i
find is figuring out how to not be too
enmeshed
um
i don't know if you have any uh
ideas about how to ensure that the teams
don't get too enmeshed sometimes
just like in the overlapping projects
yeah or just you end up being kind of
like the like software and like the tech
support for the
product you know like in a weird kind of
way where you
trying to maintain some agency over
direction while also trying to help
people kind of meet challenges that are
a bit too
too much for them
um
yeah i think it helps if you can to have
like someone in that support role for
them where their their role specifically
is to support them so you can kind of
focus on the things that you want to
focus on
um
you know that's that's kind of where
we're at as well where we don't want the
data scientist time
on our team
focus on cleaning the data for the
actuaries
um so so
we have a role that's available so
that's
that's their specific responsibility is
providing kind of like that data
engineering role basically um you know
in some organizations we have data
engineers
that do all the data cleaning and
preparation before the data scientists
actually do the work
um
and so i think
from that example alone
i'm not sure if that would help if you
have another position opened up to
provide that support
which is hard to ask i think you know
right you know just making a position
available for that
um
it's really difficult
yeah well i mean usually
people think i created the data science
item for to hire someone so they're
gonna they'll figure it out
so i think that's been our challenge too
is advocating for data engineering so
yeah yeah
great thanks
thank you javier see you have your hand
raised
thanks rachel yeah i just had a quick
question for um robert if you don't mind
robert do you have
any platforms or infrastructure to
deploy like a shiny app or something
like that
you mean like uh using connect or
something like connect or ec2 or
something like is that something you
guys have working right
now we have connect um
working
on our network
yeah sort of like behind a firewall and
then we have shiny apps that is for
externally facing stuff
yeah we're gonna work toward
connect outside the network
overnight soon or a combination of like
a github action self-hosted runner but
yeah it's it's tricky
with the on workoff network we're hybrid
but mostly on-prem so it's challenging
i i just wanted to bring up an idea i
haven't built it yet for my own company
but um just on monday i had a demo of
rnr studio for our finance and fp a team
and they're sort of all over the world
so slightly different functions
but none of them were familiar with r at
all and they had heard of python but i
mean they're like living and breathing
in excel and google sheets
and um
i built
that
like i don't know what the right
solution is but i built for them a
tutorial of like
how to install rstudio how to install r
an intro to dpplier an intro to tidier
like really basic stuff
and
i actually don't i think it was too much
for them
because
immediately after i got like four
requests the next two weeks to meet with
you know different individuals to see if
i could help build something for them
um
and i've seen this online but i'm almost
thinking i need to build a shiny app
that is just like a drag and drop thing
it's got a file upload they can upload
their excel file i mean you know
it shows all the fields they can drag
and drop and then export it
um
yeah i think someone already made that
actually yeah i i know i've seen it i
just haven't dove too into it
um
the s squeeze package is how it is
yeah i know that's the one for
visualization that's the built-in one
for our studio but i think that there's
a shiny app that does that you can just
hook it into a data source and kind of
drop stuff i thought about that too it's
like a way to
because we just did a training with like
180 people and now i'm getting a lot of
emails about right how they want work
bench and i'm like i
so i'm trying to figure out how to get
scale infrastructure for them but yeah
yeah
it's the the processing time like they
were trying to just pivot data long and
do a calculation off of it and excel was
bombing out google sheets was bombing
out
it's like just run this through r and it
would take five seconds you know
anyway sorry
if you find that feel free to share it
in the chat too
for some reason i was picturing the the
drag and drop one of s squeeze or
however you say that package but
it sounds like it's something else
but that sounds great
um i see there are other questions too
one on slido that came through
anonymously which was darren what is the
size of data sets that insurance
companies analyze and collect
um descriptors is okay too big small
very big perfectly fine just curious
so um in terms of the data sets we work
with we can work everything within
memory on our servers
um so we don't have to use like spark or
you know
you know some some online jupiter
notebook with you know lots of compute
resources
um
so our art problems aren't big data
problems um but that's not to say that
within an insurance industry like that
doesn't exist because it does it's just
that the data that we work with it's
pretty structured
um and
it we just haven't had
the need
to leverage those types of tools
but everything that we're doing is it's
them with our studio workbench in the
cloud so it's not like it's on our
laptops with you know 16 gigabytes of
memory so
um
we do have some additional capabilities
on the cloud to handle everything in
memory
darren i'm just going to chime in here
as the other insurance data scientists
so i can give an alternative view so
you know like darren you could have
extremely small data sets of insurance
that you can operate on your laptop
right without a server
or you could have very detailed
telematics data where you're talking
about
tens of billions
of records
right so our data can get quite large
depending the type of company and the
business that you're operating in
10 billion
wow
yeah we don't work with any iot
type of
data
but that's a big thing now insurance for
auto especially
for sure
serge i see you asked a question in the
chat if you want to ask that live
yeah thanks um
over uh say a decade there have been
trends related to uh changing premiums
uh based on behaviors that the um
the insured can control
uh two examples i've listed one would be
smoking versus non-smoking if you don't
smoke at least in the united states you
can pay a lower
insurance premium and so that's
particularly a motivator for people to
change their behaviors the other one is
safe driving
and there are these little monitors you
can put in your car
in exchange for giving up a little bit
of privacy you might be able to get
lower
premiums
two others that i'm particularly
interested in
are
related to the environment one is the
idea that
if you uh clear some space around your
home in a western forest for example you
might be able to
pay lower
fire insurance premiums
or if you live near a coast
and you know there's an increasing
likelihood
of storms uh say in the the southeast of
the united states
you might um be able to pay
less
um you know sort of flood insurance if
you build your house on stilt or
something like that this is kind of more
of an insurance question than a science
question although the data science part
comes
in terms probably of how do you price
these things differently
and
a question is are there other kind of
examples and insurance and property and
casualty insurance that you can think of
where
there are emerging
differentiators between classes based on
a user's behavior that they
in theory for control
yeah that's that's a really interesting
question um i don't have
um any thoughts to that um maybe russ if
if you work with anything um on your end
that you can think of but i like the
idea of you know if you're controlling
for
um you know the
your your yard and and clearing out that
area so that there's
less um you know
plants around your your your
property then that should theoretically
reduce um
the risk of fire is happening um but i
think the problem with that is like you
have to make sure that you get recent
satellite imagery um
so that's a technology you know
uh hurdle but you know maybe that that's
something that will come over time but
russ did you want to take it over
yeah i mean serge you nailed a couple of
them right um although i i would highly
doubt any of those characters really
affect how much you're paying it's more
on the eligibility side
you know i've worked in the past on a
lot of
computer vision models where you're
using satellite and drone data for
primarily commercial properties but
even in residential right your roof
condition
right the type of roof you put on your
house is going to be very important too
uh those are used in pricing and
personal insurance for your homeowners
right
um you know build a rubbish model
essentially looking at what's
surrounding a business right it appears
there's a bunch of trash you know maybe
it's not a risk we'd like to ensure
brush like you said brush tree overhang
is really important right you could have
trees fall on your house but also
it's a bigger fire risk like like you
mentioned uh
something you can't really control is
how close you are to other buildings and
structures right an adjacent structure
catches fire you're at a larger fire
risk
um rachel not not exactly what you
mentioned earlier but density to other
autos right you can generally look at
traffic patterns around you know a
particular zip or subzips area right and
a lot of
you know i'm sure progressive at
allstate have baked that into their
geospatial pricing uh today they're
pretty slick um but i think in terms of
like other behavioral type
characteristics
uh you should be aware like insurance
companies are getting very slick and how
you're performing on their other lines
of business that you may have right so
you're getting a homeowner's quote and
you have an auto policy with them they
can use the characteristics from your
prior auto experience to price your
homeowners right
if you have rachel unfortunately if your
car is being backed up into a lot that
could signify you're not as good of a
homeowners or renter's risk right so
um just be wary of that kind of stuff
like people are starting to mat you know
you know
locate their customers across the
different lines of business and marry up
that data
interesting
yeah the the rotary near my house isn't
isn't good for insurance prices either
you're you're you must be from the
northeast like i called around about the
mid in the midwest
yeah roundabout rotary yeah nobody calls
it a traffic circle
um
i know we're a little bit over darren
you said you had a few minutes is it
okay we go through a few other questions
okay
awesome um andreas are you still on
yes yes you want to ask your question
sure i would hate him because it's not a
real data science question just to pique
my own curiosity but i work in
infectious diseases and i've known that
even pre-covet there were some
small insurance companies that tried to
price insurances to protect against
various infectious disease threats
and i'm just curious of now with covet
that has become a big topic everywhere
in the insurance company or is it still
a very niche one that only if you are
pursuing because what i've heard talking
to those people is the real hard thing
is to get historic data to actually
price these things properly
um
yeah i i don't have much to comment on
that but i know it's still i think it's
still an issue of concern because if
it's
it's still a risk that that exists you
know you don't know what this end of the
year is going to look like
so so making sure that the
um insurance that we have business with
right now that they're
going to you know continue operating and
paying for their premiums like that's
still something that
we would like to happen right so
um i think it's still something that the
insurance industry is still aware of
it's just not as
focused on now because everyone's kind
of moved
on to something else
um but you know i think
how that ends up depends on how
the situation with covet is
by fall and winter
i see
ishwar had a great question i think he
had to drop at the top of the hour so i
just want to read it
but it was i have seen a lot of time
that the models are built and deployed
but mostly they go unused by the
business customers
how do you handle that situation on
training customers or creating the
business use
use case with the model not only in the
beginning of the project but after
deployment
yeah i think follow-up is really
important and kind of setting that
expectation ahead of time um you know we
i think we're not alone in that
challenge um so
i i definitely
set time aside
intentionally
and it's like okay we have this release
and so i will fall with you you know a
month from now and then
you know create those intervals a little
bit longer over time just to make sure
that they're getting the value out of it
um because sometimes they just end up
having a different priority and they can
kind of lose focus on it so
making sure that you know we keep in
touch with the stakeholders and
um just chat with them how things are
going um sometimes that leads into like
other projects that that they might have
that they want to work on and so
um that leads to new things that our
team can help out with
so i think as long as you're you know
staying in touch with that the business
side and communicating with them
throughout the whole process and that
whole process includes you know post
deployment um i think it's really
critical
for sure and
i see um jenny you just asked a question
in the chat too
around the linkedin group you want to
jump in
oh
hi i am i just was wondering darren if
you'd be willing to
um post a description of the data
science menu and the playbook
that that you talked about earlier
i failed to take notes
but yeah these these two things are
going to become increasingly relevant um
for me
as uh our team is going to be
um incorporated more into the product
team at at my company
so
you know it's one thing for us to talk
about
projects amongst ourselves but then
yeah having some kind of formal way to
interact with the product team would
be super helpful
so i if you if you're willing to do that
you mean on the linkedin group yes yeah
yeah
yeah i can i can provide an example um
basically like it's like a template
almost
how we do it but it's basically an email
for that for that menu of like hey like
here's what we do and then this is the
projects we worked on um but it's very
high level so
uh it's not like
here's everything that we've worked on
and like every single detail about it so
it's just kind of to get their attention
um and then that playbook
uh yeah that's that's that's um i think
that's not applicable to
um you know our
specific role in our company it's kind
of just like a general data science
playbook so it has some basic stuff to
it so i can i can share that with um
the group on linkedin okay great thank
you perfect and i just put the linkedin
group in the chat too if anybody isn't
part of that
yet um yeah and feel free to keep
discussions going there as well
you don't have to wait for me to share
the summary of the week you can start
your own discussions there too
one last question i want to ask you
darin is if there are specific resources
or maybe books or podcasts that you'd
recommend to us all
oh um
i don't have time for podcasts um and i
don't commute anymore so i haven't been
listening to anything
um
for me
i think a recent book i read was
the making of a manager
um by julia zoe um
she
i think worked at facebook um as a ux
designer and then she eventually was
really early on in facebook's time um
and then she's kind of you know put in
this position to become a manager and
it's like how do you how do you lead a
team when you haven't done that before
and so i i've read it um once a long
time ago and i'm kind of going through
it again
um just to remind myself of you know
things i should be aware of and
um i know it's good to kind of review
every now and then too um just to kind
of make sure that i'm
um
i don't know
just for new ideas and stuff uh i think
for me
being a leader of a team
you know it's always like how does that
what does that look like and what kind
of leader do you want to be and how do
you keep people engaged and
keep talent too especially right now
right um and how to attract talent um
those are all kind of new things for me
and things i think about a lot so
um
that's that's been relevant
that's great thank you i just put the
link to that book in the chat too i'll
put it with the the summary on linkedin
as well
thank you so much daryn for
sharing your experience with us and
answering all all the questions and
thank you all for all the great
questions as well
and happy to be here thank you so much
you